andrew lansley there are mounting a
defense of public health england
now in august last year the 19 year old
harry dahn was killed when his motorbike
crashed into a car outside a u.s
military base
in northamptonshire anne takulis the
wife of a u.s intelligence official was
involved in the crash she fled back to
the u.s
claiming diplomatic immunity it sparked
an international row with an extradition
request lodged by the uk government
rejected by washington back in january
and tomorrow the man who turned down
that request
the u.s secretary of state mike pompeo
will be in london to meet the foreign
secretary dominic raab
harry's mother charlotte charles has a
message for the two men
and she joins us now um thank you so
much for being
on the uh this morning i know this must
be an incredibly difficult thing
to talk about um charlotte how
difficult have the 11 months been since
harry's death
oh my goodness sophie i don't even know
where we would even try to begin
uh beyond excruciating every single day
you know we have to wake up every
morning knowing that harry isn't with us
and we have to try to live with that
you dream about him at night time and
you wake up and you feel angry and
bitter that we've been left with our
with our family in complete tatters and
in ruin
and still don't have justice for him
we're tired
um so still very much determined
to get that justice the determination
still burns extremely strong
but we're tired and we need the uk
to work really hard really hard with the
us government now and
and bring a closure to this bring her
back and
get that justice and do not allow us and
force us to go into a second year of
fighting
i just want to say how much i appreciate
you talking about this i know how
difficult it must be we really do
appreciate you you know
talking about such a horrific experience
for yourself and your family
um of course nothing could make up for
losing harry but
how important would it meet be how much
would it mean to you
for anne sir coolest to return to the
united kingdom
everything absolutely everything
that promise i made to my boy the night
we lost him
needs to be filled it needs to be
fulfilled it needs to be completed it
has to be
it's the only way it's the right way
it's the right thing to do
everybody no matter what crime's been
committed
expects justice and and this is a case
that shouldn't be any different to that
you know we all agree that diplomatic
community needs to be
in place for the right circumstances
this isn't one of those circumstances
this
isn't something that they would be
setting a precedent for
by sending her back this is something
that immunity does not
cover it needs to be
done justice needs to be done i need
that justice to be done the whole of our
family needs
the right thing to be done and we need
to feel
that heaven forbid should
ever happen to another family which
we're working desperately hard to try
and make sure it doesn't
that family would need to feel like the
uk are on their side
it's so important to feel supported by
your own government
and unfortunately we we just haven't had
that
but it's never too late so just help
help us
help us help us get this promise
completed
please mr secretary just to turn to you
um the uk government has filed an
extradition request
to the united states and the prime
minister and the foreign secretary have
also raised the issue with president
trump and also with
the secretary of state pompeo a number
of times they say
what more practically can the uk
government do
sophie good morning and again just thank
you so much for having us on i can't
tell you how much
it means to the family and to have this
platform to speak
directly to those in power so thank you
again it it
it's very very simple what now needs to
happen because we've had
lots of words um we've had
tons of support from the media and the
millions of people around the world
but what we now need from mr johnson mr
rob as
secretary pompeo comes tomorrow is
action
and what we want now and i've asked this
of mr rob
several times is a very clear uh
timetabled structured plan to bring and
seculas back it is no longer
any good and i'm sure if he's coming on
he'll tell you the same that they raise
it continually
that means nothing to the family let's
not forget
that almost a year ago an american
citizen
took the life of a british citizen and
was allowed to walk away
she needs to come back actions have
consequences
this is one of the most egregious abuses
of human rights
america has ever committed um
on a british citizen a british family
where is the special relationship
there must be consequences so what are
we going to do
are we going to expel diplomats are we
going to expel
the ambassador are we going to impose
sanctions
are we going to stop extraditions the
other way because there's there is no
reciprocity
if mr rob can come forward this morning
and speak
speak to us and tell us what he is going
to do in clear
specific terms and he usually comes on
these programs with a pre-prepared
script
so sophie please don't let him wriggle
out of this a
clear specific plan if the united states
are not going to send her back what is
the united kingdom going to do
with specificity to make sure
that that this terrible wrong is righted
are you worried at all i heard you say
there what special relationship
are you worried at all that particularly
with such a volatile
president that the uk government feels
that they can't
they need to keep america on side at
such a
important time in global affairs with
you know from china to russia to iran
absolutely sophie and we are very well
aware of the
geostrategic imperatives here and the
sensitivities
but what have we come to when
we lose a child and and both governments
effectively ask this family
to walk on by as far as we're concerned
i know we've got 5g and huawei and hong
kong and
russia and china to worry about as
secretary pompeo visits
but as far as we're concerned harry
has to be number one on the agenda this
is about human rights
and america professes to be the champion
of human rights
um how can secretary pompeo come here
this week with a straight face and
preach to the world
about human rights when you've got the
most gorgeous family my dear friends
who live 300 yards up the road from me
um
suffering terribly it's hypocrisy in the
extreme so we're very well aware of
those tensions
but this is the united kingdom's
opportunity uh
mr robb's opportunity to show the nation
that he is going to fulfill his first
duty
which is to safeguard and protect the
lives of uk citizens
we've got a uk citizen sitting right
next to me he needs to stand up to the
united states now
uh everything will be fine when
antsakulis comes back the world is not
going to fall apart
no precedent will be set but what will
happen
is we can give this family the
opportunity to get the justice that they
so desperately need
and then the closure and then sophie
then we can all move on and go back to
those terribly important
uh global affairs that you that you just
mentioned okay thank you
uh both so much for being on the
programme
in particular thank you to you charlotte
as well for talking about something that
i know
is incredibly difficult thank you thank
you